um all right let's talk about ideas to
make a thousand bucks this weekend uh we
what did we do i think we did it before
at um
uh
we did it a couple of weeks ago and i
asked joe and i think it was only 500
and his first response was to go and be
a caddy at the local golf
course and you could easily pick up 500
bucks if you carried like saturday
sunday if we try to get to a thousand
dollars what ideas do you have all right
here's a great idea that
most people aren't gonna do because
they're gonna be afraid to do it but i
think you could kill it all right and i
think you can build a much bigger
business on top of this
i would do a couple different things
but basically it's all centered around
legion so i would use yelp and i would
find a service that has a lot of
liquidity so basically uh relatively low
reviews and but lots of reviews and so
that would be like well that's a service
that a lot of people have
um and that maybe people aren't exactly
satisfied with it so in my head i'd be
like all right so there's a lot of like
pent up demand and angry people i could
deal with that
and i would go door to door and let's
say it's um
let's say it's house painting or let's
say this one this one's even better in
austin where i i live most of time
there's a storm and everyone's plants
got destroyed like all of our cactuses
got destroyed i would knock door to door
and i would try to and i would spend all
day doing it how many doors do you think
i could do in a day like let's see five
minutes a door uh i don't do public math
right now you probably let's say it's 10
let's say that you could knock on 10
doors per hour
all right 10 doors an hour so then 100
doors i think
i can get the leads
uh lead information so i think i can get
20 people of a hundred i think i can get
no i didn't get 10 people
who say yes i need
my uh plans to be fixed yep yeah i need
them to be fixed and i would track all
their information how many plants they
have and i would say and i would be like
the kindest person ever be like oh thank
you i'm gonna i'm gonna handle this and
then i would immediately go to yelp and
i would call the top 10 providers and i
would sell those people's information
and their lead information to each
person for ten dollars a piece i think i
can make a thousand dollars in one day
doing that and i know a guy who did this
and eventually turned it into a much
larger company it's very simple it's
called lead gen look you're either
selling your own [ __ ] or you're selling
someone else's stuff that's how the
world works and i just think i can sell
other people's [ __ ] for a good amount of
money and make a thousand dollars in a
day what do you think i think it's
absolutely possible uh and i love the
idea of basically getting the leads not
actually doing the work because you're
gonna outsource it to somebody who's an
expert who probably is gonna do a better
job than you are and my guess is that
once you have those leads uh you can
call them up for other services as well
and you almost become their like
concierge for
all kinds of things they need at their
house right so it's plants today but
all of a sudden they need their grass
cut and if you did a good job in terms
of the plants i'm assuming that you
could slowly creep into other areas but
you already have the lead and you
basically could just resell the lead to
uh
multiple times yeah yeah yeah of course
you can sell the same lead multiple
times so i think that's what i would do
and i think i could do it and i think i
would crush it matter of fact i might go
do it now
um
do you ever see what uh garyvee does
with that garage
sale flip
dude
i do that sometimes you 100 could still
do that by the way you just go to
goodwill and you bring the ebay app and
you scan [ __ ] and it tells you how much
it recently sold for
it that's like the it's so fun i've done
that a ton of times that's great um and
you can sell it on facebook marketplace
and you don't have to put it on ebay
facebook use facebook facebook
marketplace is highly underrated john
here uh put a motorcycle up for sale on
facebook marketplace i'ma make him tell
the story because it's all time but he
ended up i think selling it on facebook
marketplace right yep yeah all right
tell us the story of what happened first
and then tell us how you sold it uh yeah
i was in new york city i put a
motorcycle up for sale um someone
responded with hey are you willing to
trade and i said trade for what and he
responded with just an absolutely uh
terrible car a lot of miles all this
stuff so i said my bike was listed for
like 3 500 i said yes what type of
motorcycle oh it was a ktm duke 390.
so it was uh i said yes i will accept
that trade if you also throw in 3 500 of
cash
and he
proceeded to call me a smart alec and
tell me my bike better not get
stolen a badass so the guy who wanted to
trade him he said sure i'll take your
card that isn't so great plus you got to
give me 3 500 bucks
all right but how did you end up selling
it somebody else on yeah listed it on
facebook marketplace sold it uh facebook
marketplace is super underrated
yeah it's so underrated and if you have
a pickup truck uh it's very underrated
uh because you could do like these
arbitrages so if you live i lived in san
francisco and i would buy stuff in napa
uh which is like an hour away and i had
a suv and you could buy a lot of big
[ __ ] and just
do an arbitrage or you bring it to san
francisco and resell it i think you
could kill it also by the way
if you wanted to make a thousand dollars
just own a pickup truck and just move
stuff for people i i we well i've had to
pay people so much money in austin just
to move [ __ ] the other day i paid a guy
five hundred dollars and he was just a
kid with a power washer that he bought
on amazon for 200
to power wash my driveway
um and it was on uh what's the app
called uh taskrabbit
so i think of you i'm convinced power
washing is one of those like super you
got to get the equipment obviously but
you can even rent it you don't even have
to buy it uh and it just takes time and
nobody wants to do it but uh it's such a
huge
like inflection point for the way that
the driveway looks or the house looks or
whatever that people will get it done
and you can charge really high rates and
then you use their water it's basically
just labor and then the cost of renting
the equipment
yes and then eventually you hire cheap
labor and you build them out for twenty
five dollars an hour or fifty dollars an
hour and you give them twenty dollars an
hour yeah i was gonna say we used to do
it with the uh snow shoveling when we
were kids yeah we did the snow shoveling
but the problem is you can only do so
many in a day so you eventually have to
get other help and outsource it to other
people what we used to do is when it
would snow we'd basically run outside
and uh we would go to all the native
persons like hey hey can we can we uh
you know shuffle your driveway but the
two keys were one we'd be like all right
well we'll come back and do it in a
little bit because we would have to go
to like another one so we'd basically
beat everybody there get them to agree
and then like we didn't do it right then
later but the second thing was
huge huge controversy in snow shoveling
driveways do you have to do the whole
driveway or do you just do the tracks
because because if you do just well that
costs more money if you do the whole
driving yeah if you just do the tire
checks you can get it done really
quickly and they'll pay you like 80 of
what they would pay you to do the whole
driveway but when you're like 12 14
years old like the whole driveway is
like that's a that's a tall task the
tracks like we could like run through
that in like an hour and so we used to
try to convince them be like hey can we
shovel your driveway and as soon as they
said yes we wouldn't bring up the tracks
versus the full driveway we would just
tell them what price it was for the
tracks and then you every once in a
while you get a guy come and say hey i
thought you guys were gonna shovel the
driveway not two lines down the driveway
yeah we're kids man we're kids
i think dude i think in order to make
some money um
like a lot of people because we're on
youtube right now and everyone's
watching online they i immediately go to
like what [ __ ] can i make online
i would not default to that at all if i
wanted to make like 150 200 000 a year
on my own and i wasn't very good at
online stuff which most people aren't i
think um i would totally just um
do all this manual labor [ __ ] and by the
way you want to hear a crazy story yeah
i've got a mother my mother-in-law is
from haiti okay and she came from haiti
when she was 18.
she knew how to sew a little bit and she
one day about two years ago she took me
to the airport and it's about two hours
from new york city and she goes hey can
i drive to the airport and i was like
why because i just want to ask you a
question about internet stuff and so i
she was fine i go fine she drives me and
she goes hey explain how do you sell
stuff on the internet and i was like oh
this is just another time that like
someone's gonna ask up and they're never
gonna follow through so i told her about
like conversion rate and i tell her
about like how to buy ads somewhere so
about two weeks later she sends me her
etsy page and it's called smithy home
couture and it's these fancy pillows
that she's making for like 150
okay and i was like wow this is amazing
she goes yeah that's me i did that and
this year she'll probably do
250 to 300 000 in revenue this year
and she doesn't she doesn't have a
website it's all it is it's an etsy page
and she has at first she was just sewing
pillows out of her uh house
and now she's got a small office and a
part-time employee it's pretty nuts and
so building stuff just to sell on top of
like a lot of really popular platforms
like an etsy um and ebay and amp like
amazon you can crush that you don't even
need a website
i've got a uh a brother um who well we
have a brother i guess he's not my
brother he's all of our brothers uh who
really uh enjoys building things with
wood
and he'll like make like crazy crazy
stuff like uh one time he gave me a
cutting board
but it looks like a chess board and it's
literally different colors of wood all
like uh put together and i said to him i
was like dude you could sell this for
250 300 bucks easy and he's got a real
job so he can't sit there all day long
and make it but my guess is that he
could crank him out at a pretty fast
rate and uh and he just he's not
interested in it but when you have that
skill and you enjoy doing it you might
as well make money at the same time
yeah i agree i agree what if i was doing
a cutting board thing i would make
cutting boards i my
whenever i think of these like those
cool things i always think i want to
make it localized so i want to make it i
want to make it all about states you
ever like notice on buzzfeed dude check
this out so there you know how on
buzzfeed um if you say like wait where
are you guys from pump you guys are from
north carolina
what city
raleigh
so it would be like 18 reasons why you
know you're from raleigh
and like the likelihood that a rally
person clicks at is like crazy height
right
and so there's this idea that you
basically people who are from somewhere
they always want to see
uh
uh they always want to see their name or
their friends names or their city's
names on paper it just you know it makes
you feel good and so there's this old
guy who had this newspaper and he and he
was the best-selling newspaper when all
newspapers local newspapers were
declining and he goes i'm going to tell
you three words why my newspaper is
crushing names names names all i do is i
list as many names as i can because
people love seeing their name or their
friends names and so
that's just like the psychological
principle and so buzzfeed used to launch
these articles and so this guy who
worked at buzzfeed created this thing
called homesick candles so if you google
homesick candles you'll find it and so
they made candles for each state
and they made it smell like that state
so washington was like wintergreen uh i
don't know what new york was but like
you know they
[Laughter]
yeah like can you have like a trash like
this
yeah that's exactly what it is there's
so
a good guide
and so they
this principle i think you could apply
to so many different things
uh just have a missouri that's where i'm
from a missouri shaped cutting board
you're in business bro it's over uh lily
chang uh from the chat who actually is
one of the winners that we talked to uh
on zoom she said that when she was in
college a girl scout would go around to
the greek houses on thursday night to
sell cookies and the little girl and her
mom would sell a couple hundred boxes a
night
like going to college campuses and
selling like you know you were talking
about the bars with hot dogs but selling
anything to college kids around food at
night i feel like is a grand slam right
dude i used that i used to sell during
the day for three dollars it was you
know it was four dollars for a sausage
in the day and at nighttime the same
thing was eight dollars
price gouge
yeah so you just double the price yeah
but but i mean that is exactly how uh
how it works right and you also are
looking for uh college kids at the
opportune moment obviously if you're
outside of a bar and you've got food
they're likely wanting to to buy it but
you can you don't have to necessarily go
sit outside the bar either if somebody's
selling the the cookies on a thursday
night outside of the greek houses that
works as well right
yeah and that's what i used to do and i
i i used to kill it i mean but here's
the thing though
it was [ __ ] hard work it was so hard
like i was like physically exhausted at
the end of every day and then i
discovered the internet and i started
making money on the internet and i was
like
oh my god this is so good this is the
best thing ever and i remember making
like uh my paypal going off in my phone
in finance class and then i eventually
left school because i was like dude i
just made more than you teacher like i'm
not listening to this kind of class but
um
it's so hard working with your hands and
your body it is it is definitely
exhausting
so uh zach said that girl scouts set up
cookie stands outside the marijuana
dispensaries in chicago the fact he used
the word marijuana means he's a cop so
it's a weed dispensary uh in chicago
but uh very smart obviously if you're
gonna set out a setup outside there and
then um what did somebody say oh when
you're drunk eight dollars for a hot
dog's nothing
someone said you don't even look at food
prices when you're drunk
dude there will be days where i uh so i
was in nashville at the time that's
where i lived and you know how like
cities have uh these like free concerts
where uh you know during the summer time
where they like shut down the block and
like you know tens of thousands of
people show up so i used to work those
and i would come home with three grand
four grand in cash uh and i would work
like an 18-hour day but i would i killed
it i used to call it being hood rich i
would just have a lot of ones and fives
and there's so much money i mean three
thousand dollars when you're when you're
20 is like game over you win yeah i'm
the richest guy ever
all right if you had to pick one
internet idea for this weekend is there
anything that you think you could get
set up by the end of the weekend and
book a thousand dollars
all right i'll tell you something so i
have this thing on gumroad so years ago
i used to own a roommate matching
business it was a very bad business but
what i learned is if you're in a major
city uh new york
uh la
san francisco and you post that you have
like like you you live in a three
bedroom and one of your roommates just
moved out and so you have a spare
bedroom uh mo because there's so many
young people moving there who can't
afford their own one bedroom they want
to move with roommates and if you posted
an ad on craigslist you would get like
50 to 100
applicants meaning
most applicants aren't gonna get it
right and so i wrote a guide on how to
land an apartment because i knew how to
do cold email
and i created this guide on gumroad let
me see if i can find it here it is this
guy to this day makes me
thousands of dollars a month here it is
you wrote a guide on how to respond to
open roommate inquiries and like be the
one accepted in the apartment
yeah the miracle craigslist template bro
there's a name for it the the miracle
craigslist email template and i said
that's a great name
it's a great name i sold a [ __ ] ton of
these and it was a very very simple
problem and the way that i got customers
at first and by and i'm getting to the
point but the way i got customers is i
posted fake ads for an empty apartment
on craigslist and then i had an auto
reply that emailed them back and said
i'm sorry there's no apartment but like
i made this thing if you want to use it
here it is
and that's how i got my initial
customers and it's and it made over a
thousand dollars in the first month
and the way that i hosted this was on
gumroad and for anyone who's listening
who doesn't know what gum road is gum
road is a godsend gumroad is the
greatest thing to dumb it down they
probably don't like those but basically
it's the easiest way to sell a pdf
and what i would do is i would troll
twitter
patrol linkedin and find a variety of
different like problems that i think
that like one per like one very specific
group has
and i would create like a guide on it i
would go and read a book or i would read
something where i would just summarize
something and i would uh put it into a
pdf
and i would dm them on twitter and try
to sell it to them i buy you everybody
do you ever buy anything from gumroad
i think i have once or twice i actually
don't remember what it was but uh it's a
really easy experience it's like one
click two clicks and then you're done
dude it's so easy and so i i i i buy
[ __ ] from gumroad all the time like if i
have a very very specific problem like i
want um
uh like i want uh a summary of a book or
uh what what else are there uh i want
well like a lot of people will summarize
like 50 bucks and i'll like scroll
through all the books i'm like oh that's
great and they just sell it on gumroad
so i read it um another one is uh that's
a great will that's a great idea
yeah it's easy it's easy stuff or
i don't know i mean there's like a
thousand different use cases of gumroad
but it's really great for selling
incredibly specific use cases and so
that's if you want to make money online
i think and you're just starting out
that's what you have to do is you you
don't really want to go if you don't
like if you're not if you don't have
millions of dollars to raise in funding
just do a very very specific thing so
the miracle craigslist email template
the most specific thing you could
possibly have and that makes me
thousands of dollars a month and so if
you want to make money online i think
and you you you don't have a lot to blow
and you're kind of a noob do a very
specific thing for example i could
summarize or trans do you transcribe the
podcast
uh sometimes not always
great perfect example i would go to
rev.com and i would get your top like 50
episodes i would go to
the pomp's pi
on itunes you go to podcast you you sort
by popularity
um and i would or you go to youtube you
sort your videos by most viewed i would
transcribe them and i would write my
analysis of them and i would list all
the links that you talked about and i
think i could sell that on gumroad yeah
you probably could somebody said mr hood
rich's baby arm hot dogs trademark it
that's pretty good we also uh somebody
who works with us who probably doesn't
want to be named said that if he was
broke right now
he would create a product hunt product
review show
because there's too many products that
get posted on there for to try all of
them so basically he would go he would
try them all in the back all right
listen i know that this thing there's
all this voting [ __ ] but like
everyone's gaming it like here's really
the two products today that you need to
pay attention to i would do one better
here's what i would do is i would do
make it an email a daily email where you
just say here's the top three things
that launched in product hunt the day
before
uh so i would do like the day after and
so the day before i sent that email i
would email the people who have the
business and i would say give me an
affiliate link because here's why a lot
of software businesses they give you an
affiliate that's 20 of revenue per month
so if the software product is a hundred
dollars per month they'll give you
20 a month
if someone buys it through your link and
so i would do it and so product hunt
they never have had affiliate links and
i've always thought that was the
stupidest thing ever and that they
should they would make so much money and
so i would just look at product hunt and
i would look at like the top things that
were huge i would dm them on product or
on twitter and say hey i'm going to
promote you can i get an affiliate link
that gives me 10 or 20 of the revenue
that i send you and uh
i would send that email out and i would
do that every day
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help